eu vim aqui falar hoje sobre os três
erres que eu acredito que vão salvar a
gente aqui porque a gente não salva o
planeta né
mas a gente se quiser continuar aqui
precisa salvar a gente mesmo
essa história toda começou há seis anos
quando eu assisti um documentário o
trash
nele o ator jeremy arnoux percorre
vários lugares do mundo
investigando o que a gente está fazendo
com o planeta como a gente está
transformando a nossa casa num grande
lixão a céu aberto
quando eu saí do cinema eu tive muita
raiva
eu tive muita raiva da indústria que
diariamente coloca aí no planeta
toneladas de lixo sem ter a menor
responsabilidade com isso eu tive muita
raiva do governo que poderia sim legisla
e criar uma história diferente mas
aparentemente tem feito muito pouco em
relação a isso e eu me senti muito mal
por ter raiva porque a raiva
erroneamente é vista como um sentimento
ruim
um sentimento que a gente não deveria
ter a final
bonito é sentir amor só que a raiva é
muito humana todo mundo sente raiva ea
raiva não é ruim
a raiva quando bem canalizada é um
instrumento muito poderoso
a joana mês se é conhecida como uma das
grandes mestras da ecologia profunda ela
tem uma frase que eu gosto muito que
raiva é paixão por justiça
aquela raiva me mobilizou através
daquela raiva eu entendi que eu não
poderia mais se a mesma não poderia
continuar depois de assistir o trash
fazendo as mesmas coisas que eu fazia e
eu saí da internet comprei um copinho eu
decidi que eu ia começar a minha
transformação para não colaborar com
esse planeta que não era o que eu
concordava
cheio de lixo eliminando os copos
descartáveis
pra mim os copos descartáveis eles fazem
uma analogia muito boa com que a gente
está fazendo com o planeta e com a nossa
vida a gente usa a gente descarta que a
gente acha que aquilo está sendo jogado
fora mas a gente não faz isso só com
plástico descartável de um copinho
a gente faz isso com celular a gente faz
isso com a televisão
a gente faz isso com as pessoas a gente
faz isso com os momentos que a gente faz
isso com que realmente importa quantas
vezes a gente está num jantar que a
gente tá no celular
descartando aquela pessoa que está
sentada na nossa frente
descartando aquele momento que a gente
está vivendo ali então a partir dessa
raiva em 2015 eu criei - um lixo porque
eu não podia mais colaborar com o que
estava acontecendo durante o filme na
verdade eu entendia que era gaia falando
comigo gaia estava falando comigo
através das imagens que houve uma delas
era essa da ilha de plástico do pacífico
que é uma área 17 vezes em portugal 17
vezes o tamanho de portugal de plástico
no oceano pacífico é uma grande sopa
plástica porque a gente joga no oceano
13 bilhões de toneladas de plástico por
ano anualmente a gente não fizer nada
para mudar o nosso consumo em 2050 vai
ter mais plástico do que peixe
então essa raiva que não é o primeiro r
eu quero falar mas é um r também é
importante me fez agir criar esse
movimento porque quando eu achei esse
filme eu estava vivendo uma vida normal
eu estava vivendo uma vida como a
sociedade acha que é normal que para mim
significa vá trabalhar com moda e nove
portas de roupas cheias 9 porta de
armário cheio de roupa na minha casa e
passar às meias finais de semana fazendo
aquilo que as pessoas acham que é normal
e na praia conversando com meus amigos
falam da minha idade saindo enfim o
trash foi um soco no estômago
o trash na verdade foi uma lembrança foi
uma lembrança de que eu não estava aqui
pra fazer isso quando eu saí do thrash
eu me lembrei que quando eu tinha 10
anos de idade
eu tinha ido na rio 92 a conferência que
aconteceu aqui pra falar de clima e eu
estava em angra passando férias com
minha família no bairro do meu tio para
onde eu ia muito e aí eu falei pra minha
mãe eu sei que eu quero ser quando
crescer quando eu crescer quero ser
ecologistas ecologista um termo que
ninguém sabia muito bem que significava
e aí ela falou assim para mim minha
filha mas você não a campa
você também não come hoje paciência não
vai ser bióloga né então ecologista
esquece não faz isso e aquilo ficou meio
adormecido e aí depois disso é que se a
advogada que esse agente do fbi talvez
essa raiva por justiça já tivesse aí
desde muito pequena
só que o fbi era um pouco longe de ser
advogada pra mim mais parecia uma grande
encenação e eu fui trabalhar com moda
que eu achava que era uma coisa que eu
gostava que eu era apaixonada e eu
fiquei dez anos trabalhando com moda e
um dia aquilo começou a fazer mais
sentido e o meu coração começou a falar
comigo
fernanda não é pra isso que você veio e
aí eu fui pra comunicação achando que
essa mudança é resolver o problema que o
problema estava na moda e não deu não
ter encontrado ainda minha missão aqui e
aí eu passava os meus dias têm uma
agência de comunicação agindo
normalmente mas sempre estressada sempre
puxado nunca completamente feliz e
quando assistiu fred me lembrei o marmi
regenerou dessa regeneração veio - um
lixo que é esse projeto que eu lancei em
2015 como uma das formas de exercer a
minha missão aqui porque quando a gente
regenera a gente não regenera só a gente
a gente começa a regenerar o todo esse
processo de regeneração do planeta é
muito importante porque a gente não vai
salvar o planeta
o planeta se estava sozinho só pra gente
entender o tamanho disso ele está aqui
há 4,6 bilhões de anos a gente a 200 mil
nesse meio tempo já tiveram os
dinossauros que ficaram por aqui 700 mil
anos e o planeta extinguiu os
dinossauros
eles não existem mais perto disso o que
que é a gente a gente nada a gente a
poeira de estrelas mas como a capacidade
de bomba atômica de destruir o que a
gente está vendo
por isso a regeneração r muito
importante a gente fala muito de
reciclagem de redução de reuso nessa os
erres da sustentabilidade
mas enquanto a gente não pensar que tudo
que a gente faz aqui tem que ser em prol
da regeneração porque a gente já deixou
um déficit absurdo a gente não vai estar
aqui amanhã
a partir dessa regeneração começa uma
reconexão uma reconexão da gente com a
nossa natureza humana
o nosso corpo é formado em 80 por cento
por água não tem um índice maior de que
nós somos natureza do que isso mas a
gente ainda usa nas nossas explicações
na maneira de pensar
essa dualidade nós ea natureza
a gente não se não se enxerga como
natureza
às vezes nosso objetivos de vida o
motivo pelo qual a gente estuda e
trabalha é ganhar dinheiro
isso não é natural do ser humano a gente
tá muito desconectado da nossa própria
natureza
quando a gente se re connect a gente
comece um processo de cura um processo
de cura que começa pela gente mas acaba
sendo uma cura de todos porque a gente
está ligado por uma grande teia uma teia
invisível mas muito poderosa que a teia
da vida
ela é invisível como o ar que a gente
respira
só pra fazer uma analogia de com
poderosa ela é a senhora a gente não
está aqui inclusive falando nisso quando
as pessoas respiram ar puro a pressão
arterial delas diminui não atou em
cidades grandes como rio são paulo a
gente tem tantos casos de hipertensão
quando a gente está em contato com a
natureza por exemplo sol
a gente produz vitamina d que além de
fixar o cálcio nos ossos
faz com que a gente se sinta melhor e
mais alegre mais dispostos que é o
oposto do estresse que vem sendo causado
pelas nossas escolhas diárias
por conta dessa desconexa são as
crianças que não passa o tempo na
natureza sofrem do que recentemente foi
cunhado como transtorno de déficit de
altura e pesa pelo richard lobb um
cientista
isso pode gerar adultos com défice de
atenção
míopes e obesos é meio óbvio que se a
gente a natureza a gente precisa estar
conectado com ela porque é dela que a
gente se nutre e que a gente vai fazendo
é transformar a natureza um grande lixão
é usar o que a gente chama de recursos
da natureza para o nosso bel prazer
satisfação ou o lucro que é o que a
gente vê acontecer diariamente a gente
está no meio de um momento em que está
sendo discutido se a gente tem que
legalizar o desmatamento da amazônia
para que ela seja recurso sem amazônia
não chove
sem chuva não tem água aqui no sudeste
ea gente não vai sobreviver mas a gente
ainda está falando de recurso natural
como esse recurso natural não fosse a
gente como a gente não tivesse conectado
esse é mais ou menos o nosso tamanho
e esse é mais ou menos o tamanho do
problema só que quando a gente se
reconectar a gente começa a entender que
existe um micro existe um macro e na
verdade é tudo uma coisa só
é uma grande teia uma grande analogia às
vezes a gente faz uma ação muito simples
que tem uma repercussão muito grande
quando comecei o projeto - o lixo as
pessoas falavam pra mim
a gente acha que vai mudar alguma coisa
com esse corpinho
eu falei 'bom eu não sei mas eu fernanda
não pode continuar sendo a mesma pessoa
eu me lembrei foi muito desconfortável
assistir o trash foi muito
desconfortável fisicamente é muito
desconfortável ficar na cadeia
assistindo aquele filme
mas na verdade foi muito desconfortável
ver a pessoa que eu era foi muito
desconfortável entendeu com desconectado
eu estava e por isso é tão importante o
centro rsr da reconexão o copo do - o
lixo que hoje é esse
foi uma mudança estrutural em mim que me
fez exercer a minha missão hoje na terra
que é ativista ambiental e muita gente
me pergunta mas peraí
se o planeta se salva isso a gente
continua nesse momento econômico que a
gente usa recursos como recursos porque
você faz o que você faz o que faz uma
ativista ambiental e eu digo que se
ativista ambiental é um ato de amor é um
ato de amor pelo planeta é um ato de
amor pelos seres que dividem essa casa
com a gente mas principalmente é um ato
de amor pelo ser humano porque é ele que
pode não estar aqui amanhã
então quando a gente pensa na nossa
existência e quando a gente pensa que o
planeta vai se reinventar com
dinossauros em dinossauro com a gente ou
sem a gente a gente começa a entender a
proporção ea urgência que a gente tem
que agir
esse calendário cósmico é uma analogia
da nossa existência no mundo
carl sagan que é um astrônomo ele
resumiu
ele fez uma proporção de toda a
existência do universo desde o big bang
até hoje
se isso coubesse em um ano se isso
coubesse um ano e se a gente pegasse lá
o começo de tudo até hoje o ser humano
teria surgido no último dia às 22 horas
e 24 minutos e tudo que a gente conhece
desde a revolução industrial toda essa
história que a gente é tão familiarizado
e todo o começo do fim dos recursos
naturais teria acontecido no último
segundo
de fato somos poeira cósmica
só que a gente ainda tem uma chance de
se salvar aqui com regeneração com
reconexão
o respeito porque respeita o outro r
muito poderoso
primeiro o respeito à nossa natureza a
nossa verdade somos todos agentes de
transformação em potencial para o bem
isso só está adormecido respeitar não é
ficar parado respeitar não é falar a
beleza o respeito às diferenças
respeitar e agir é agir com coragem agir
com o coração porque respeitar significa
a gente se reconectar com que a gente
realmente veio fazer aqui no meu caso eu
comecei com um copinho essa história
no meu caso é ativista ambiental mas a
gente não precisa se ativista ambiental
para respeitar a natureza
a gente não precisa ser ativista
ambiental para lembrar da nossa verdade
para lembrar que somos natureza e para
lembrar que ainda dá tempo
ainda dá tempo da gente regenerar o
planeta ea raça humana
ainda dá tempo de a gente se tornar
humano a gente não nasce humana a gente
nasce uma noite
a gente só se torna humano quando a
gente entende a nossa natureza aqui
quando a gente pratica empatia quando a
gente entende que a gente só vai
sobreviver se a gente viver em comunhão
e gaia o planeta está falando isso pra
gente o tempo inteiro está tentando
mostrar isso pra gente o tempo inteiro
então chegou a hora da gente agir com
respeito e com coragem que é o que vai
fazer com que a gente continue aqui eu
queria pedir pra todo mundo agora fechar
o olho pode fechar gente pra fechar pa
obrigado eu queria pedir que seja
respirarem fundo
e ouvirem o que seu coração está dizendo
o que ele pede pra vocês fazerem
não censure o que vem eu comecei com um
copinho
podem respirar fundo de novo e abrir os
olhos
devagar eu tenho certeza que o coração
de cada um aqui falou uma coisa muito
importante para ser feita e que tem a
ver com a natureza de vocês e que se
vocês acreditarem
vocês vão lá e vocês vão fazer
obrigado